les paroissiens de montigny et voisins
sont à l'étroit dans leurs églises 185
places en l'église saint-martin de
montigny 300 pour saint pierre dulac 175
places pour voisins le bretonneux ce
n'est plus suffisant pour accueillir les
1200 à 1500 pratiquants qui fréquentent
ces lieux de culte le dimanche elle est
beaucoup trop petit d'ailleurs si vous
constatez un peu les
l'état d'edo messe du matin du dimanche
matin on se retrouve souvent avec des
passes en dehors c'est une grande
difficulté à vivre les célébrations et
assoit cueillir le fait d'être entassés
les uns sur les autres et aujourd'hui
nous savons bien montigny plus de 30000
habitants voisins bretons ne plus de
10000 habitants sont inadaptés en fait à
l'affluence des chrétiens qui
habituellement se retrouvent dimanche
pour qu'on se retrouve à avoir des
église bondée et les églises qui ne sont
même plus en capacité d'accueillir de
nouveaux fidèles le diocèse de
versailles a donc donné son accord pour
la construction d'une nouvelle église de
800 places sur le territoire de
voisins-le-bretonneux un projet lancé
depuis au moins six ans cette église
pourrait être réalisée sur la pointe
collège sur le terrain réservé à la zac
de la remise des discussions sont en
cours avec la mairie de
voisins-le-bretonneux et la communauté
d'agglomération nous sommes en cours de
discussion pour voir les modalités
notamment de l'implantation de cette
église à cet endroit allez les
achèterait le terrain comme tout
entrepreneur privé le ferai et puis
après de se construire l'église à ses
frais l'amérique ne ferait que vendre le
terrain une première note d'information
a été diffusé aux pratiquants ce
dimanche une décision finale ne devrait
pas être prise avant la fin de l'année